today on the matt wall show united
airlines has decided to start hiring
pilots based on diversity
rather than merit this is yet another
conservative slippery slope argument
come to life also
five headlines including joe biden
equivocating on whether companies should
boycott georgia over their voter id law
caitlyn jenner considers a run for
governor and a former cia director
becomes the latest ex-government
official
one of many to publicly entertain the
idea that aliens may have already
visited earth
in our daily cancellation we'll talk
about tucker carlson's interview with
the governor of arkansas
last night he attempted to defend his
position in favor of chemically
castrating children
and it did not go well all of that and
more today on the matt wall show
you know we've seen all kinds of
emergencies over the last year some
bigger some smaller
some weather related some not we've had
situations here in nashville
just recently there was there was
flooding really bad storms all of this
just shows why you need our sponsors
ready wise
brady wise is the leader in emergency
food supplies and it's all about being
prepared
ahead of time because that's what
preparation is all about you're not
prepared ahead of time then it's too
late
emergency meals they've got they've got
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on-the-go nutrition they've
also got adventure meals for hiking
camping and outdoor activities if you're
you know someone who likes to hang out
outdoors like i am ready wise makes
being prepared simple and affordable you
can order online and have nutritious
meals shipped directly to your doorstep
ready wise products are proudly made in
the usa
and you know this the great thing is
very simple when preparing their
products all you need is four cups of
water the water doesn't have to be hot
you just
pour the food into the water stir and
cover 15 minutes later the meal is ready
it's that simple ready wise uses the
finest ingredients and latest food
preparation technologies you don't have
to sacrifice
taste just to um get the convenience
of of ready wise so if you want to be a
part of this this week
my listeners get 10 off at readywise.com
when answering walsh at checkout or by
calling 855-475-3089
readywise is a 30 day no questions asked
return policy so there's no risk in
taking the initiative to get you
and your family prepared today that's
readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e.com promo
codewalsh
to get 10 off as a conservative
you can be confident of two things when
you make a slippery slope argument in
relation to any left-wing idea or policy
first
that you'll be condemned as a paranoid
lunatic and promptly laughed out of the
room
second that you will almost certainly be
right
every week yet another thing happens in
reality that people on the right
in the not so distant past warned would
happen if we stayed on this cultural
trajectory
precedents do matter which is no
surprise to some of us
if if something is justified on a
certain basis then everything else that
can be justified on that same basis
will probably one day occur if you tear
down statues of confederate generals
because they were racist
then all of the other statues of
quote-unquote racist historical figures
will come down if you say that marriage
is only a consensual contract between
people who love each other then
eventually you'll have children with
you know three polyamorous homosexual
fathers listed on their birth
certificates
if you say that it's possible and valid
for a person to choose his own gender
then eventually you'll have thousands of
children
undergoing gender transitions if you
justify
broad masking mandates during a pandemic
you'll end up with masking mandates even
after the pandemic
doesn't take fortune tellers to predict
these future events
it requires only a basic grasp of logic
because evidently one thing really does
lead to another
who would have thought the problem is
that the slope
is we have to admit sometimes so
slippery and the logical endpoints so
irredeemably absurd
that it's impossible to issue a warning
about whether about where these things
are heading without sounding like you're
making a joke
i mean i'll admit that so for example
you know those of us
who opposed those of us opposed to
affirmative action have for years
illustrated our point by asking you to
imagine
you know situation where you're boarding
a passenger plane
piloted by someone who was given the job
uh to fulfill a racial quota
rather than based on merits i mean no
matter how committed you are to
diversity
uh we would say when you're 30 000 feet
in the air traveling 500 miles an hour
you want your captain to be the best of
the best no matter his race or gender
it would surely be small comfort as you
plunge into the pacific
due to human error by your
underqualified yet inclusive flight crew
to know that you know the wreckage will
be diverse and eclectic
but this is the sort of catastrophic
insanity to which
our emphasis on diversity over merit
leads
that's what we've always said right and
now united airlines is here to prove the
point this is another time
when we have to say i told you so and we
really do hate to say it
on tuesday united tweeted out the big
news this is what they said
our flight deck should reflect the
diverse group of people on board our
planes every day
that's why we planned for fifty percent
of the five thousand pilots we train in
the next decade
to be women or people of color the
airline news website one mile at a time
has more details they say quote
united airlines is the only major u.s
airline to own a flight school
and the airline is beginning to accept
new applications as of today as it
embarks on a plan to train 5 000 new
pilots by 2030.
upon completion of the program pilots
are guaranteed a job with united
that's cool in and of itself as we the
article continues
as we see how the industry expects there
to be so much demand for pilots in the
coming years
what's even cooler is that united is
setting a goal of having at least half
of those pilots be women and people of
color
just to show you why this is needed a
mere five percent of airline pilots in
the us are women
even more jarring is that just over one
percent of airline captains are female
meaning
a vast majority of female pilots are
first officers so it shows you that
progress is being made
in the sense that there are more
entry-level pilots than senior pilots
who are female
but it also shows you how much more work
there is to be done the percentage of
u.s airline pilots who are people of
color is even
smaller and perhaps the most shocking
statistic of all
is that there are fewer than 150 black
female pilots
at u.s airlines
yes cool is one way to describe this
plan by united i think
uh maybe a better word would be
something like um horrifying
you know that might get closer to the
mark to this point
okay the safety record of the airline
industry
is almost miraculous millions of
commercial aircraft fly through the
skies each year and fatal accidents are
still
so rare that as people like myself with
unreasonable anxiety about flying have
to constantly remind ourselves
you are orders of magnitude more likely
to die in the car on the way to the
airport than you are
while you're up in the sky in the in the
plane you are in fact
more likely to die almost anywhere else
on the planet
than at cruising altitude on a passenger
aircraft
it is if not the safest place to be then
very close to the safest place you could
possibly be
anywhere now this has a lot to do with
advancement in technology but it's also
a reflection of the incredible skill and
competence of the people steering these
giant metal buckets over the clouds
and now as it turns out there is no
miracle or mystery here
actually people both those building the
planes and those flying them
have made flying as inconceivably safe
as it is today
and it really is inconceivable millions
and millions and millions of flights go
by
and no one dies
again you can't say that about cars
that's for sure
this is a long way of saying if it ain't
broke don't fix it
almost every person who has ever boarded
a plane has arrived at the destination
they had in mind intact and unharmed
almost every single person almost
what that tells us is that there
probably is
no major widespread problem with the way
that they select pilots
whatever they've been doing up until
right now keep doing that it's working
the fact that this record of success
belongs mostly to men
is not a problem it's not jarring or
shocking it's not something that we need
to fix
if men in general have made the best
pilots so be it
if anything if we're going to do
anything with that information
wouldn't we be recruiting more men not
fewer
wouldn't we be saying well men appear to
be pretty damn good at this let's
let's get some more of them
or better yet it's a reason to continue
recruiting pilots exactly as they've
been recruited until now
which is not based on gender at all the
process has worked
splendidly it literally could not have
worked any better
now united doing a little pr damage
control which will prove
easier than the sort of damage control
they might be doing in the near future
responded um concerns on social media by
claiming that all
applicants will still be qualified okay
they wrote and listened to the language
here they wrote
all of the highly qualified candidates
we accepted the academy regardless of
race or sex
will have met or exceeded the standards
we set for admittance
notice what they didn't say they didn't
say that
that the most qualified candidates will
be accepted only that
every candidate will have met their
standards this leaves
them open to accept one candidate who
merely meets the standard
over another candidate who exceeds the
standard
you notice what they also didn't do they
didn't promise that they won't lower or
change the standard in order to fulfill
this quota
which they're going to have to if you
want to go from
five percent women to 50
um you're gonna have to change this
obviously the standards you have in
place right now
those really high standards so that only
the best of the best the best get
through
you're gonna have to lower them but it's
not gonna work otherwise
that's what the military discovered
which is why they lowered their
standards too for women
now defenders of these sorts of quotas
will often try to have it both ways even
today there are leftists online claiming
that
you know united can still hire the best
of the best even while ensuring that
half
are women or quote people of color but
this is really a one or the other
proposition it really is if you're
hiring the best of the best
you cannot possibly declare ahead of
time what
race and gender and in what exact
proportion the best of the best will be
if you can stick to hiring the best of
the best while still succeeding in
hiring 50 women
then there's no need for this quota at
all what's the point
the fact that they need the quota means
either that they are confessing to
deliberately discriminating against
women and black people until this point
or that they're moving away from hiring
the best applicants
in order to hire the most diverse
applicants
so which is it united are you confessing
to illegal discrimination and are you
preparing now to pay out
the billion dollar settlements that are
coming
or are you announcing a plan to hire
less qualified pilots in the future
again it is really one or the other
those are the two options
i'm guessing the latter is the case here
united will risk
killing you in a plane crash if it
scores them a few woke points
that's what this is wokeness destroys
everything even things that were almost
perfect it destroys like the safety
record for airlines
almost as close to perfect as a as a
as a thing can be in this in this flawed
world that we live in
and you know if this is the point if
this is the
plan and since i'm not gonna be flying
united anyway because i value my life
um i'd suggest that they go all in i
mean why stop at only including more
women and people of color in the cockpit
here's a jarring stat for you can you
believe this
no member of the blind community has
ever been hired as a commercial airline
pilot
can you believe that that that's
incredible i mean surely the wright
brothers
would have burned their invention had
they known it would lead to bigotry of
this kind
i mean all all of these years of of
commercial
air flight that there's there's never
been a blind pilot
if united is breaking glass ceilings why
not this one
i mean they're going to be breaking
quite a few ceilings in the near future
i imagine
they ought to add this to the list too i
would only request
that the passengers on united's historic
first flight by a blind pilot
should be all of the executives in the
company who decided to put diversity
above the safety of their customers
put them all in a plane and send them up
on the um
the plane being flown by a blind pilot
that's what i would say i mean surely
these executives would leap at the
chance to be a part of history
and then to shortly become history so
come on united
show us all show us all how progressive
you really are
let's get now to our five headlines
[Music]
i've been telling you for the last few
weeks about our friends over at
constitutioncoach.com
and you really got to pay attention
because we've got we've got these
classes coming up on april 25th
and if you're not signed up yet um
you're you're coming up to
your last opportunity to get signed up
constitutioncoach.com they've got a lot
of great programs for equipping citizens
defend liberty by studying and living
out the constitution
um and uh this is all part of their
constitutional defense course and
there's the physical aspect of it which
is the firearms training
and i've done that they do it at the
premier training facility in the nation
uh in nevada and it's um it's just it's
a lot of fun and on top of that you
you come away with a skill set that you
didn't have before
so you've got to join you can join
hundreds of other patriots from across
the nation for a time of learning
training and fellowship with like-minded
people
whether you've shotguns your whole life
or you've never touched one or you're
somewhere between it doesn't matter
these people took me to an entirely new
skill level will do the same for you so
don't just get a gun
learn how to carry with confidence and
get the training you need
go to constitutioncoach.com again rick
and the constitution coach team
have another class on april 25th but
it's filling up fast
uh you only have a few more days to get
signed up so right now is the time to do
it
constitutioncoach.com today you watch my
video there to find out more about how
you can be a part of this one-of-a-kind
training
that's constitutioncoach.com number one
so joe biden
is uh equivocating now a little bit
he was we know that he was he was fully
in favor of the
mlb all-star game moving out of georgia
it
punishing the people of georgia because
the uh the legislature and and the
governor
you know came up with a bill that that
would protect the integrity of elections
so this is this is insane on
on multiple levels of course um
why would we need to punish anyone for
trying to protect the integrity of
elections
and if you are going to punish somebody
for this why would you punish the people
of georgia
business owners and so on who are losing
tens of millions up to 100 million
or more because of this joe biden was in
favor of that
and but now he's because if we're
talking about slippery slope
okay if you're moving uh the major
league baseball out of georgia for this
then what about all the other
professional sport events that
happen in georgia there are quite a few
of them and biden was asked about that
yesterday and here's what he said do you
think the masters golf tournament should
be moved out of georgia
i think that's up to the masters
look
you know it is reassuring
to see that
for-profit operations and businesses
are speaking up about how
these new jim crow laws are just
antithetical to who we are there's
another side to it too
the other side to it too is when they in
fact move out of georgia
the people who need to help the most
people who are making
hourly wages sometimes get hurt the most
i think it's a very tough decision for a
corporation to make
or group to make but i respect them when
they make that judgment
and i support whatever judgment they
make but it's
the best way to deal with this is for
georgia and other states to smarten up
stop it stop it
oh that's a good argument
it's hard to argue with a point like
that it's so salient
stop it stop it
why should they stop it what's wrong
with what they did stop it just stop it
come on guys
just stop it okay the new jim crow
my god jim crow again
i'm waiting you know i'm waiting for
someone
to provide even not that this would
would
even begin to prove their point but can
you give us an example
of one person one person
who wanted to vote
and was not able to because of a voter
id law
can you even explain how that would work
on a theoretical basis can you explain
how that worked how that works exactly
and the better question is can you
explain it in a way
that won't come off as incredibly racist
because remember what you're what you're
suggesting is that uh it's not
that people in general have trouble
figuring out how to get a
an id what you're saying is that black
people
have trouble figuring this out
specifically
so can someone can some white liberal
explain that in a way
that makes sense and is not racist i
haven't heard it yet
and then after you've done that give us
the example of someone
really wanted to vote they had um two
years
or depend four years if it's for talking
just presidential
uh to to get an id and they were not
able to do it
and because i want to know who that
person is and i would like to talk to
that person
and i want to find out how they operate
in life how do they go about their daily
lives without a photo id
as an adult you need it to do almost
anything
so what is what is your living in a a
life as a
as an adult in modern society um
without an id and unable to figure out
how to get one like
what is that like what is your
day-to-day existence like
well we never get that and now now biden
is saying well maybe we don't let's not
move everything out of georgia
as long as they spark smarten up and do
what we say then uh
that's the best thing
now meanwhile for more um insight into
this issue i thought we should really
turn
to someone who is a legal scholar
uh one of the great minds i think in in
society today and certainly in media
this is shannon sharp along with skip
bayless
on the fox sports show undisputed and
here he is
uh for some reason this is a sports show
and for some reason he's chiming in on
voting law and all that kind of stuff
and here's what he had to say i like the
move by mlb
i like that taking a stand and skip at
some point in times you're gonna have to
put action to your words
you say you're about inclusion you say
you about uh doing the right thing at
some point in time you have to put those
actions into words
i mean put those words into action
that's what they're doing now
you're going to be relegated where you
can take this game to because there's a
lot of other states that are doing the
exact same thing as georgia
texas florida so those florida you off
the list
texas you're off the list there are a
lot of states that are doing the exact
same thing
that georgia is that georgia did that's
what i don't understand and this is
what's confusing with me
mitch mcconnell lindsey graham was on
the under ticket
for president trump president trump lost
the election
because of fraud but they won the
election they won their senate races
it was fair and square i'm confused skip
how does that work
well the top got lost but my election
was fair and square so let's do
something about it
now in 2016 we know for a fact russia
tried to interfere
mitch mcconnell would do nothing he
wouldn't bring it to the floor
now you want to put these rights because
what they see skip there's a change
there's a changing of the guard
more people are becoming of age to vote
and they're minorities
and they're voting so instead of
changing your messaging and try to reach
out to a new base
what do you do we're going to try to
restrict so you can
it shouldn't be harder to vote than to
get a gun now what's wrong with that
picture skip you notice that they're
making it harder
for you to vote then to get that done no
we don't want to do nothing to god
though i want my second amendment
right what's wrong with that picture
skip what's wrong well what's wrong with
that picture is that it uh it's you're
you're you're hallucinating shannon
that's what's wrong with the picture but
probably there's a lot wrong with the
picture it doesn't exist
it's a picture that you drew it's like a
stick figure picture that you drew
somewhere i don't know it's not it's not
reality
that is i love when when people make up
something and then they become offended
by it can you believe this
it's harder to to vote and get a gun is
outrageous
yeah i mean i it's if you're making
things up it's uh
anyone could do that i can make up all
kinds of outrageous scenarios now
i say this as someone who i've been
clear that i don't actually think it
would be outrageous i think it would be
good if it really was harder to uh
to vote than to get a gun i think that's
the way it should be but it's not that
way
at all and we've gone through all the
reasons why
now you watch a clip like that and i
know it's easy to say anytime i play
any sort of clip like that from whether
it's a celebrity or somebody on sports
media
the comments that i always get people
are probably leaving the comments right
now if they're watching on daily wire or
youtube
um the comments are why what does it
matter what this person says who cares
what this person's
uh it does it shouldn't matter
right but it does it actually matters a
lot more
a lot more than anything that anybody
says on cable news
what you just heard there is the same
nonsense that you hear on cable news
but on cable news it makes very little
difference because the people that are
exposed to it on cnn
are already the people who believe this
stuff that's why they're watching cnn
right um or they're watching cnn because
they're
in an airport and they're but they're
not really watching it they have their
headphones on and they're watching it
like on mute or something
um but as far as people choosing to tune
in
to cnn it they already believe this and
they're watching it
so that they're told more of what they
already believe it's the old echo
chamber thing now here
a whole lot of people who um are
impressionable
because most people are and
it's they're not tuning in to get
propaganda
but they get it and it sinks in
unfortunately the average audience
of sports media that's nothing against
people that watch sports media i watch
it too it's like the average audience
anywhere
they hear a claim like that and if it
seems to kind of confirm their priors
and it sort of seems to fit in with the
vague impression they have of the world
in reality
they're going to accept it like there
are
probably thousands of people that heard
that segment
and came away thinking wow yeah it's
harder to get a
gun than to vote well that kind of makes
sense i guess that's true that's amazing
that's that's horrible
and who's responsible for this the
republicans well we got to get them out
of office then
that really they're not going to go and
look it up and google and
spend even five minutes researching that
or thinking critically about it
they're not going to go to the next step
and think wait a second hold on
doesn't a gun cost money i mean right
there
that alone is is a is a barrier to entry
that you don't have for voting something
that that alone
makes getting a gun harder along with
everything else no they're not going to
think that
you know most people are not critical
thinkers that's what it comes down to
and so what you just heard there very
influential makes a big difference
shouldn't but it does all right
uh number two here's dr fauci
on cable news puzzling this is on what
is msnbc he's puzzling over the fact
that cases are going down even as people
ignore him
if you can believe it i can but he can't
here he is
you mentioned texas in that full
ballpark in arlington yesterday
there was a lot of concern last month
when texas effectively opened up
dropped all those restrictions and said
it's back to life and if you go to
texas as you know it looks like 2019 the
restaurants and the bars are full and
open the ballparks are full and yet
we've seen cases in hospitalization
since then continue to tick
downward so what do you make of that as
all of us
look around and sort of try to consider
how safe it is to get back to normal
life
yeah you know it's it can be confusing
because you may see a lag
and a delay because often you have to
wait a few weeks
before you see the effect of what you're
doing right now
you know there are a lot of things that
go into that i mean
when you say that they've they've had a
lot of
uh activity on the outside like ball
games
i'm not really quite sure it could be
they're doing things outdoors you know
it's
very difficult to just one-on-one
compare that you just have to see in the
long range
i hope they continue to tick down if
they do that would be great but there's
always the concern
when you pull back on methods
particularly things like
indoor dining and bars that are crowded
you can see a delay and then all of a
sudden tick right back up
we've been fooled before by situations
where people begin to open up
nothing happens and then all of a sudden
several weeks later
things start exploding on you so we got
to be careful we don't prematurely judge
that
yeah what he says before i assume he's
going back uh you know months ago
before we there are millions and
millions people vaccinated
many millions of people more who have
already been exposed and are immune
that's what we hear guys for like fouchy
now that it's that
in their mind it makes no difference
like they they we're still supposed to
believe
that there could be you know a massive
spike and suddenly we're back where we
were six months ago
that's what we're being told that's what
we're supposed to believe
but if the vaccine works that should
basically be
if the vaccine works and also your your
convert immunity by
prior by if you if you previously had
um the virus but we're told both of
those things
then it should basically be impossible
at this point that we all the sudden
find ourselves nationwide back where we
were
six months ago because of all the people
that are immune to it
but fauci is uh it i mean you gotta see
from his perspective he knows that
eventually the time is coming
when he's not gonna be getting the cable
news hits anymore no one's gonna care
what he says
eventually eventually society's moving
on from him and he's not
he doesn't have the power that he does
he doesn't that he has right now he
doesn't have the fame and the prestige
and everything
um he's gonna be yesterday's news you
know one hit wonder and
he he's he's afraid of that moment a lot
of these people are
a lot of these people that have been
bureaucrats have been in public life
working for the government for years for
decades suddenly finding themselves as
these rock stars and
they don't want to lose that status so
they're going to say whatever they can
to hold on to it
all right by the way the actor morgan
freeman
if you're wondering has chimed in
about vaccines and uh and here's his
message
i'm morgan freeman i'm not a doctor but
i trust
science and
i'm told that for some reason people
trust me
so here i am to say i trust science and
i got the vaccine
if you trust me you'll get the vaccine
and math is called the distributive
property
in people it's called taking care of one
another
get the vaccine help make our world a
safe place for us to enjoy
ourselves again please
but why would i trust morgan freeman
who who is this the creative coalition
and a bunch of other companies
morgan if you trust me you'll get the
vaccine why should we trust morgan
freeman
i better really have an opinion on
trusting him or not trusting him he's
just an actor
but again it's just like with the the
shannon sharp clip we played
you know you and i maybe if we're
critical thinkers will say i don't care
what morgan freeman i mean my opinion on
the vaccine isn't going to be changed
one way or another by the fact that
morgan
yeah he's got he's got he's got a nice
voice and um a very authoritative
sounding voice we all like to
listen to things that are narrated by
morgan freeman obviously
but it doesn't actually make him more
trustworthy just because we like the
sound of his voice
as critical thinkers you and i we know
that but there are a lot of people who
that is really their thought process
they think well morgan freeman he played
god didn't he and in one of those movies
well
if we can't trust god then who can we
trust
all right number three this is from the
hill it says caitlyn jenner is
reportedly eyeing a bid for governor of
california
um the former keeping up with the
kardashians reality tv star and olympian
is talking with political consultants
as quote she actively explores a run
um and uh apparently what i had read was
that
there's someone from the trump team
involved in this actually no surprise
there
you know and and uh of course they they
always make
you've always got all kinds of
interesting people running for governor
in california so that's
that's par for the course but i am
seeing some conservatives
online who are saying this is great you
know i have caitlyn jenner
republican the the then then
the left's not going to know what to do
you know we we we play the left's
identity politics game against them and
um
and and they'll be totally disarmed
it doesn't work that way how many times
we have to see it doesn't work that way
in order to play the left's identity
politics game against them to use it
against them effectively
they have to have integrity
and live by their own standards which
they don't
so yes it you know when when when
they've got rachel levine
as the assistant health secretary and uh
if you
if you criticize rachel levine they're
gonna say you're automatically a
transphobe
it's not gonna work that way you might
you might wish that it would but it
doesn't work that way if the republican
governor of california is
transgender and then you know the left
criticizes
him and then you think you can say well
that makes you a transphobe
they that's their standard they don't
they only apply
it to us they don't live by it no matter
how often we complain that they don't
live by they're not going to
and also this you know this gender stuff
gender theory as i have been saying for
years
even as many conservatives laughed about
it and told me
you're going to die on this hill this
isn't the hill to die on i was told it
was a sideshow i was told it was
you know a passing fad it won't matter
as i've been saying for years and have
there's another one of those i hate to
say i told you so situations but
i was correct and and i'm still correct
that this is one of the defining issues
of our time
so we can't embrace left-wing gender
theory
in hopes of playing their identity
politics game and using it against them
like it's gonna be some great chess move
it's not gonna work
we lose a lot more than we gain
uh okay number four the new york post
uh reported yesterday disney world said
tuesday that customers will be allowed
to temporarily take off their masks
while posing for outdoor
outdoor photos beginning thursday disney
world did not comment further on what
prompted the updated guidelines
which now say that face coverings must
be worn at all times except when dining
or swimming
so as it stands there's the reason i
read that as it stands right now
at disney world you have to wear a mask
at all times while at the park
even on the rides and you're only
allowed to take it off for pictures or
to eat
and as far as eating goes you you can't
do that or drink
while walking around you have to do in
the designated areas that's been the
rule since
june you also have to submit to
temperature checks on your way in
and if you don't submit then you could
be arrested and that happened to a guy a
couple days ago he was arrested at
disney world because he didn't want to
do the
temperature check um and this is all on
top of the standard disney world
trappings
you know thousands of dollars you have
to pay between the tickets the hotel
travel etc 97 degree heat 97
humidity the lines the crowds and this
is something people choose to do
something they subject themselves to on
purpose they pay money for the privilege
of walking
around all day in the heat with a face
muzzle on
money leaking out of their bank account
sweat leaking out of every pore
accumulating in their masks which
they're breathing in all day as they
wait in these lines
it is hell on earth why would anyone
choose to do that
this is your vacation you get two weeks
off a year or whatever and you're gonna
spend it doing
that i can't understand
it um finally for the new york post
it says former cia director james
director
r james woolsey said he believes ufos
could exist
after his friend's plane was paused at
40 000 feet
the former chief spook who ran the
agency from 1993 1995
uh spoke friday to the black vaults
youtube channel
where he was promoting a book um and he
said
quote i never thought there was anything
to all this it always seemed pretty far
out to me but there was one case in
which a friend of mine
was able to have his aircraft stop at 40
000 feet or so
and not continue operating as a normal
aircraft i don't know exactly what that
means it doesn't go into much
explanation still landed safely
only proven the point from before now
now you've got all these
pilots who are encountering ufos and
aliens up there
still getting you home still getting you
to your destination you know you're
still going to land
in detroit on time pretty impressive um
but i really i really wanted to just get
to this part so listen to this quote
okay
from the article it says in december
xcia director john
brennan said it was presumptuous and
arrogant to believe that there are no
other forms of life than the ones on
earth
here's the quote from him he said i
think some of the phenomena we're going
to be seeing
continues to be unexplained and might in
fact be some type of phenomenon that is
the result of something that we don't
yet understand
and that could involve some type of
activity that some might say
constitutes a different form of life
that's from john brennan have you ever
heard a better example of bureaucrat
ease this is the language of a
bureaucrat it's not even
not even english you feel like you're
having a stroke when you listen to it
he's stringing words together and not
saying anything at all
this is a guy who has who has lost the
ability to communicate in actual human
language i mean listen to it again he
says
i think some of the phenomena we're
going to be seeing
continues to be unexplained and might in
fact be some type of phenomenon
that is the result of something that we
don't yet understand and that could
involve some type of activity
that some might say constitutes a
different form of life
in other words he's saying yeah i think
there might be aliens
you know what this really is this this
is this is me in seventh grade
doing a book report about a book i
didn't read
and just trying to hit the word count of
you know 1200 words
throwing in all the words i can
when i have only one thought about the
book that i got from reading its back
cover and i got it and that's all i got
and i got to put a bunch of other words
with it
anyway i guess that's not really the
main point the main point here is about
the ufos but instead i decided to rag on
john brennan instead you know if you
want to make a house into a home
then one of the most important things
you can do is have nice artwork
on the walls and that's what that's
where our friends over paint your life
come in
uh i i know for for me we recently
bought a house we're in the process of
decorating it renovating to get it all
set up
i should say my wife is doing that i
have no idea what she's doing with the
house but she just she takes care of it
and uh and all i do is live there and
it's pretty great
and that's why we recently decided to
get another paint your life
painting we already had one of our kids
we want to get another one that's how
much we like it
if you want to get a truly meaningful
gift for yourself or someone else you've
got to try paint yourlife.com get a
professional hand painted portrait
created from any photo
at an affordable price you can choose
from a team of world-class artists and
work with them until every detail is
absolutely perfect
it's a very user-friendly platform and
it lets you order a custom made
hand-painted portrait
in less than five minutes so it's real
quick on your end they're the ones
they're gonna spend
all the time making it perfect you can
send any picture of yourself your
children
family a special place a cherished pet
doesn't matter
you can combine photos into one painting
and they're gonna send you back
something that is beautiful and you'll
love that's what they did for us at
paintyourlife.com there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting
your money is refunded guaranteed and
right now as a limited time offer get 20
off your painting that's right 20 off
and free shipping to get this special
offer text the word matt to 64
000. that's matt the 64 000 text matt to
64
000 hang your life celebrate the moments
that matter most terms
apply available at paintyourlife.com
terms again text matt to 64
000. okay we'll move on to reading the
youtube comments
this is from joseph says evil to the
left of me cowards to the right here i
am stuck in the middle with matt walsh
kind of has a ring to it joe says
my main question is how in the world
were these two girls able to make a
settlement so fast
usually the court system works like a
snail yeah the girls
in dc who uh murdered um muhammad anwar
66 year old uber eats driver this
happened like a week ago
carjacking him killed him only cared
about their phone
and now they got a plea bargain they're
not going to prison at all they're going
to spend
no time in prison and they'll be totally
free by the age of 21 so that's six
years for the 15 year old a little bit
longer for the other girl
not only did they get that deal but yes
they did get it it's a very
this this was decided very very quickly
they didn't spend a lot of time thinking
about it
how did it happen joe well it's i told
you it's privilege
and it's mainly female privilege these
are the kinds of deals
that females often get in the court
system
um mrs mack says we're no longer on a
slippery slope we've hit rock bottom
well unfortunately we haven't you know
what
i i if the slippery slope argument is is
wrong or false
it is only because it's not really a
slope slope's probably not the best
um illustration to use it is it's a free
fall
into like a vacuum it just it never it's
like you're it's like you're in
outer space you can't even really call
it falling you're just
hurtling through like what that george
clooney movie where he's hurtling
through space what's that one called
that's what that's where we are now
there's no end point
you just go deeper and deeper into the
abyss
cheerful thought um
border x says most people want to want
you to play the banjo i just want to
hear the telemarketer pitch you had to
do
i imagine it being some weird
combination of soothing and terrifying
both resulting in me buying whatever you
were selling i don't remember the exact
pitch i did as a telemarketer um
but uh i i can remember that i got to
the point where i was doing it enough
that i could tell in five seconds
whether you were the kind of person who
might
buy from a telemarketer because most
people just won't
and um and if i could tell you weren't
then we our phone line might disconnect
and i'm just gonna move on to the next
person
that was um and that's and by the way
you don't get a lot of telemarketer the
telemarketers these days but when you do
the one thing i hated the worst thing as
a telemarketer
was when you encountered a polite person
who didn't want to hang up on you like a
polite but intelligent person
was the worst thing to encounter as a
telemarketer because they're intelligent
so they're not going to buy from you
but they're polite so they don't want to
hang up and what that means is they're
going to sit and listen to you
and they're gonna make you give that
whole two-minute spiel just
so that at the end they can say okay if
you're done i'm really not interested
have a great day
if you care about the well-being of
telemarketers just hang up it's the best
thing you can do
then they can move on and finally
dr emmett brown says matt would you
rather choose as a pet
a dog or a leftist
well that's a false choice because i
think all dogs are leftists
think about it needy entitled
tendency to drool very similar it's one
of the reasons i don't like dogs i think
you know you hear from some of our great
mattress sponsors on this show
and uh because we all know that you you
know we all care about what mattress you
sleep on
at night but if you care about that you
should also care about the chair that
you spend so much of your day sitting in
and that's why you need x chair x chair
has you covered for your office chair
needs
i'm sitting in one right now and
enjoying every second of it the secret
is not only their patented dynamic
variable lumber support
which offers unbelievable lumbar support
to your lower back but now thanks to
their new
xhmt technology you can also get heat
and massage therapy
while you're sitting at your desk and i
promise even though we have that feature
i use it all the time
i am not getting massage while i do the
show that is my solemn promise to you
because that would be weird
instead of of your old uncomfortable
office chair now you can look forward to
spending hours sitting in the ultimate
therapeutic
massager the aches the xhmt delivers
heat massage technology right to your
core helping increase blood flow
muscle recovery and energy so it's also
it's very comfortable but it's also
making you healthier it's for your
health and well-being as well
extra is on sale right now for a hundred
dollars off you can go to
xchairwalsh.com now that's
letter x chairwalsh.com or call one
eight four four
four x chair extra has a 30 day
guarantee of complete comfort and you
can finance your purchase for as little
as 30 bucks a month
go to xchairwalsh.com now and use code x
wheels
for free x-wheel bladecasters that's
exchairwalsh.com
now as we return from eastern passover
it's important to reflect on you know
the impact that these holidays have on
our faith and the impact that
judeo-christian
values have on our culture and that's
why we launched um
a brand new talk show with candace owens
one of the fiercest protectors of
conservative values and free speech that
there is
candace is also the only uh or rather
right now the first at least
daily wire show to appear in front of a
live studio audience
an element that's rarely been included
in conservative media
but i think it adds uh you know adds
some excitement to it it's a fresh new
factor it's a lot of fun
and uh you know whatever the left is
doing we can do it better the show
streams on fridays at 9 00 pm eastern
8 p.m central at dailywire.com but you
can also get the audio podcast
candace on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcast so if you need
some candace owens in your podcast feed
look no further head over to apple
podcast or
spotify and subscribe today and remember
to leave a five-star review if you like
what you hear now let's get to our daily
cancellation
today to somewhat rare migration the
person featured yesterday in our opening
monologue has now moved
straight away to our cancellation
monologue that's arkansas governor asa
hutchinson a man so slight and
unimpressive
that he makes eric swalwell look almost
masculine by comparison
and he is the one being canceled today
he was already effectively canceled
yesterday
upon the news that he had vetoed a bill
that would abandon the chemical
castration of children in the state
calling it a quote vast government
overreach to prevent doctors from
generally mutilating children
or giving hormone blockers to children
hutchinson
a republican governor in the south let's
remember
took the side of the most fringe and
radical elements of the lgbt left indeed
he took a side that not what five or ten
years ago even many on the lgbt
lgbt left would have opposed or claimed
to oppose
but as we know mainstream conservatism
is often just leftism about a half a
decade behind so
ace hutchinson in this case is right on
schedule
fortunately the arkansas general
assembly performed what you might call a
legislate legislative castration of the
governor by overriding his veto and
enacting the ban anyway hutchinson
apparently decided that he had
not been defrocked and humiliated enough
so he went
on tucker carlson last night to try and
defend his decision to veto the bill
now an intelligent man or at least a man
who cares about his own dignity
might have realized that his position is
literally indefensible as in it cannot
be defended and thus
he would have declined the invitation to
go on cable news the top cable news
program in the country
and try and defend it because you can't
but hutchinson
is not that sort of man and so this is
what happened let's watch
well the legislature in arkansas
recently passed a bill that would ban
doctors from prescribing so-called
puberty blockers heavy-duty hormones to
children
who believe they're transgender the law
also banned surgeons from
physical castration of children but the
governor of arkansas isa hutchinson
vetoed that bill on monday legislatures
in arkansas just voted to override
that veto which brings us to where we
are right now ace hutchinson is the
governor of arkansas and he joins us to
talk about
this story governor thanks so much for
coming on i really appreciate it in the
middle of all this
now i i think of you as a conservative
here you've come out publicly as
pro-choice on the question of chemical
castration okay
let's pause there for just a moment
tucker's
introduction of the governor and of the
issue is absolutely fair he summarized
things quite succinctly and accurately
but i want you to just reflect on on
this for a moment this man asa
hutchinson
was either so terrified of upsetting the
far left or so beholden to his corporate
interests or both i think both
that he's willing to be known he's
willing to be known now
as a man who is as tucker said
pro-choice
on the chemical castration of children
he's willing to sit there
his smiling mug presented to the camera
and take
ownership of the view that sometimes
it's good to drug
mutilate and castrate young boys to turn
them into girls
whatever hutchinson thinks that he's
winning as a result of his
self-debasement here
i can guarantee that the reward is not
worth the cost
there's no way it can be so once again a
republican has given up
everything his dignity everything
and in exchange he gets nothing
but it gets worse let's listen now to
his uh his explanation
this bill was over broad it was extreme
it went far beyond what you just said
and i made it clear that this if this
was about
prohibiting procedures sex reassignment
surgery absolutely i would have signed
that bill but this
again is the first law in the nation
that
invokes the state between
medical decisions parents who consent to
that
and the decision of the patient and so
this goes
way too far and in fact it doesn't even
have a grandfather clause that
those young people that are under
hormonal treatment okay but if
if i could just correct you for a second
well this is chemical castration of
course if you stop
puberty and suppress the sex hormones
you're chemically castrating someone
so our our description was correct but
let me just ask you i mean they're all
kinds
we're talking about minors children here
and they're all kinds of things in
arkansas
kids in every state are not allowed to
do get married drink a beer get a tattoo
why do you think it's important for
conservatives to make certain that
children can block their puberty be
chemically castrated why is that a
conservative value
if you would tell us well first of all
you have parents
involved in very difficult decisions you
have physicians that are involved in
these decisions
and i go back to william buckley i go
back to ronald reagan the principles of
our party uh which believes in a limited
role of government
all right there it is there limited role
okay ronald reagan
apparently ronald reagan was
pro-castration
yeah you know i kind of think i i seem
to remember that what was the famous
reagan quote it was uh mr gorbachev tear
off these balls
now that might be a slight
i'm prouder of that joke that i should
be i really am that might be a slight
paraphrase i don't remember exactly what
the quote was to be honest
in any case hutchinson besides
posthumously recruiting
buckley and reagan is into his uh sex
changes for 12 year olds camp
seems to provide these primary
rationales this is this is the
these are the reasons that he just gave
right um
one the government should not interfere
with the decisions of patients
two this is a difficult decision for
parents and doctors and the government
shouldn't interfere with their with that
either
and three we as conservatives should
support limited government and then four
walmart told me to say this now
admittedly point four is more subtext
as for points one through three let's
take them one at a time
first the decision of patience well as
we covered yesterday and i've covered
many times the patients are children
they can't consent they can't make this
decision they're not capable
it is incoherent to say that a 13 year
old
um can you know it doesn't create
incoherent to say that a 13 year old
cannot consent to sex and yet that he
can consent to a sex
change the same logic and science
psychological and neurological science
that supports the notion that 13 year
olds can't consent to sex which they
can't
also applies just as much if not more so
to sex changes if you take the one
position
you're logically committed to the other
second this is a difficult decision for
parents and doctors
now hutchinson here who calls himself
pro-life is echoing the exact
talking points of the pro-abortion left
we're told that killing babies
is a solemn and difficult decision that
mothers must
sometimes make in consultation with
their doctors
but the difficulty of the decision is
irrelevant
i mean it may be difficult for a wife
who decides to kill her husband
in consultation with her hit man it may
be a it's a difficult and personal
decision
she may agonize over it she may think
long and hard about it
and the thing that but the thing that
makes it difficult
is that murdering your husband is a
terrible thing to do
what makes abortion difficult is that
murdering your child
is a terrible thing to do what makes the
medical transitioning of children
difficult
is that it's a terrible thing to do
in fact in the case of medical
transition and abortion
if these decisions were really what
their proponents describe
if the people on the pro side were
correct in their view
then these decisions shouldn't be
difficult at all
if a baby is nothing but a non-human
lump of meaningless cells
why is it difficult to destroy it you
say it's just a lump of cells okay well
then what do you talk about it's a
difficult decision sounds easy to me
and if a boy really does have a girl
trapped inside him whatever that means
and you can free this this true inner
female identity through medical
procedures
that we're told have no ill effects and
no real downside
then again why is it a difficult
decision
i mean there's a there's a girl trapped
inside there get her out
but again the difficulty is uh is sort
of a moot point in deciding whether the
government has a role
and that brings us to point three
hutchinson says that this is a matter of
limited government which only proves a
point that i've made in the past that
limited government is a really
insufficient and frankly kind of stupid
slogan
for conservatism and you know we've all
shouted it i have too
but limited government has been mostly a
shield for cowards like hutchinson to
hide behind that's really what it is
uh what what it's been in practice
that's how it's worked
anytime they encounter a fight that
they're too afraid to get involved in
they can always lift up the banner of
limited government
and um and pretend that they're
deserting the battlefield out of
principle
it's like a soldier who suddenly becomes
a quaker the moment the first bullet
flies
you know he sees that first bullet fly
over his head he says you know what uh i
think the quakers had
a point you know i'm thinking about it
again i read one of those pamphlets a
long time i think you know i think i
sort of
i think i'm a quaker now limited
government conservatives have in fact at
every level from the presidency
on down expanded the government
exponentially and spent
money by the trillions but then when it
comes to protecting children from the
worst forms of abuse and indoctrination
suddenly they discover their long
dormant passion for
governmental restraint it's a joke and
we should all be too smart to fall for
it
the the banner that we should be
marching under is not something vague
and over broad and useless like limited
government
but rather something something that
perhaps on second thought won't fit on a
banner at all something like
we want a government that is properly
ordered and directed
and which uses its power in judicious
lawful and morally sound ways
in order to fulfill its fundamental
obligations to its people
like i said not gonna fit on a banner
but the point is that we aren't asking
the government
to uninvolve itself from everything
and one area where the government should
certainly be involved is in the
protection and defense of vulnerable
citizens who cannot protect or defend
themselves
vulnerable citizens such as children who
if they manage to survive the gauntlet
of the modern womb
now face the very real possibility that
they're going to have their minds warped
by radical gender theorists
and then their bodies deformed to match
their warped minds
this is a place for the government to
step in
if this is not a place for government to
step in then i can't imagine
where else government should step in if
this is not a job for the government
then what
could be a job for the government if we
if we uh
you know restrain government here then
how can we justify
exerting the government anywhere else
we can't i mean that's clear it's clear
even to ace hutchinson
but he's decided to pretend that he
doesn't understand what he certainly
does
understand and for that today
we must transition asa hutchinson to the
status of
cancelled and we'll leave it there for
today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 the governor
of arkansas defends the chemical
castration of kids the mlb moves its
all-star game out of georgia
to a whiter state with stricter voting
laws and the experts
warn of a double mutant fourth wave of
coronavirus
check it out on the michael knowles show
you